die weissberg sollte ursprünglich 40
impfdosen bekommen es waren dann am ende
100 aber wie weit kommt man mit 100
impfdosen überhaupt und ganz bayern hat
9700 ein paar zerquetschte impfdosen
bekommen
wie weit reicht das und wie ist die
stimmung vor ort wenn man auf diese
kleinen trecker dosen guckt die man da
hat ja wie weit kommt man dass diese
impfung ist ein marathon wurde schon
öfters gesagt und das ist hier eine
kurzstrecke die ganz kleine kurzstrecke
100 dosen das reicht eben für die erste
spritze für 40 menschen hier für 60
weiteren in heimen natürlich viel viel
mehr die jetzt eigentlich heute schon
eine erste spritze bräuchten es kommt
aber nachschub und zwar schnell also
schon in zwei tagen während werden es
doppelt zu also zehnmal so viele sein
wird also bayern 97.000 dosen bekommen
und am 31 werden es noch einmal 107.000
dosen dieses impfstoffs sein und bleiben
sich zu hoffen dass das nicht abreißen
dass es im gegenzug sollen noch viel
mehr werden alle zwei vielleicht sogar
jeden tag dass da schnell nachgeliefert
wird